cut my life into pieces this is my last
resort suffocation no breathing
what
no it's a song about suicide you can't
listen to music that exactly describes
the emotional thing you're going through
you know how cheesy that is
i don't listen to atlanta's more set
when i'm going through a breakup and i'm
not listening to papa roach on
the day i'm gonna kill myself
i get that you've been in like a little
bit of a slump lately but suicide's not
the answer to that
you stuck in some get a
therapist or something stop standing in
your own way i'd like to make a
return
really
this has been a lifelong thing for me
you don't know that things will get
better you tried it kevin and you ended
up in the hospital this time i'm here
we'll do all right we'll do it together
i love you man
you're my best friend i love you too
about on three
one
two two
[Applause]
jesus christ man i need one more
day you just tried to kill yourself
three days ago you had three last days i
got a rice cooking in the microwave
world's our oyster
any idea we should do with our last day
if i had any ideas i'm gonna ask you to
blow my brains out 35 minutes ago
oh
i'm over here
we're not going to see tomorrow which
means today we get to do whatever we
want with no consequences so
let's use that opportunity to do some
good i'm just doing all right
and it's a great day to be alive
but why can't everyday be just
[Music]
it's been a hell of a run my oh
song's over but the melody lingers on
dude what the are you doing what
i just said our last words why are you
trying to one-up me you did one i want
to do one it's been a hell of a run my
let's just end on that i didn't
know the last word i was gonna hear is
gonna be the end let's just
count it down okay all right
okay
on three
[Music]
you